we were sitting in the honest once in a
restaurant Casa Vega and L.A we've seen
the the Kardashians Kim Chloe Scott and
the mom and they're all sitting there
and the cameras were on them and not one
person in this restaurant cared nobody
looked over everybody was just like
eating quesadillas and [__] you know
combo platter number two and nobody
cared and then they got up and just very
unceremoniously walked out of this
restaurant
and I I something hit me I was like how
much money do you need
how much money to wear at a billion
dollars you were still sitting in a
Mexican restaurant with cameras watching
you eat guacamole
what are you afraid of losing what and
that's your thing about like not going
away these [__] have been on TV
for 15 years what do you think will
happen if you take a season off and let
other people eat guacamole on camera